the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
hi always being somebody who wants to
get something for nothing
I figure anytime in this course that
we're study the new function the very
next thing that we'll do is study the
inverse function in other words since
the inverse is just a change in emphasis
why not just change the emphasis the
result that we want so you see today's
lesson is called the inverse
trigonometric functions and the longest
part of this lecture will be a few
computations just to get the feel of
things the reason being that other than
that everything that we have to use will
be drawn from results that we've already
studied in our lessons called
inverse functions it's still the same
idea only a different illustration well
at any rate let's get on with the
subject let's start with the curve y
equals sine X now you see when we plot
the curve y equals sine X it doesn't
take us very long to discover that this
curve is not one-to-one
in fact it misses by a long shot because
for every Y value between minus 1 and 1
there are infinitely many values of X
that produce that value of Y see this is
an oscillating type of function so you
see from our rigorous point of view
there really isn't much sense in
defining the inverse sine function well
in a way this is a artificial drawback
that we have because you'll also recall
that when we talked about functions that
were not one-to-one we could always
break them down into a union of
one-to-one functions for example notice
in the part of the curve here which I've
accented namely the domain from minus PI
over 2 to PI over 2 notice that on that
domain the sine is one-to-one and it's
certainly on two onto the interval from
minus 1 to 1 in other words every value
of the sine is taken on once and only
once on the interval
- PI over 2 to PI over 2 so you see if I
disregarded everything but this part of
the curve and how could I do that what
should I name this function well why not
do something like this let me invent a
new name let me call this curve S sub 0
of X where S sub 0 of X is defined to be
sine X provided that X is in the closed
interval from minus PI over 2 to PI over
2 again be very very careful recall that
when we talked about defining functions
we said that to specify two functions as
being equal it was not enough that the
function machine was the same the inputs
had to be the same in other words two
functions had to be equal or to be equal
to Fung the two functions had to have
precisely the same domain so notice in
this sense there is a big difference
between S sub 0 of X and the function
that's being called sine X what is the
big difference well for the function
that's called sine X the domain is all
real numbers for the function called S
sub 0 of X the domain is only the closed
interval from minus PI over 2 to PI over
2 now again there's nothing sacred about
picking this particular interval well I
could have done was define say another
curve which I'll call S sub 1 of X S sub
1 of X will be the function sine X but
now the domain will be shall we say from
3 PI over 2
often PI over 2 to 3 PI over 2 in other
words notice that this portion of our
sine curve is also one-to-one and runs
the full gamut of values that the sine
can take on from 1 to minus 1 and by the
way I don't have to be prejudiced this
way either I could just as easily have
worked with negative values in other
words I could have invented say another
curve which I'll call s sub minus 1 of X
where this subscript simply means I'm
going in the opposite direction S sub
minus 1 of X might just as well have
been what the curve sine X but now again
how are all these things differing
only in the choice of the domain see now
the domain would be from minus 3 PI over
2 to minus PI over 2 again in terms of a
picture this portion here would be fine
you see what I can do is break up this
mount this curve that fails to be single
valued by a blessing of how it feels to
be one-to-one by a long shot into a
union of one-to-one curves in fact if I
wanted to use some fancy mathematical
language which I write down just to look
impressive here but if it bothers you
ignore it completely I guess what I'm
really saying is I could have defined
sine X to be the union S sub n of X as n
goes from minus infinity to infinity
meaning what take all of these pieces
with these integral subscripts and form
their Union and that infinite Union
gives you back the entire curve well
what am i making all this issue about in
the first place you see we can't have an
inverse function unless our original
function is one-to-one so you see in
fact let's see what does happened
remember how we invert the function in
other words how do you get from the
graph of y equals f of X to the graph of
y equals f inverse of X recalling from
our previous lecture on this topic what
you essentially do well if you're good
at visualizing you just reflect with
respect to the 45-degree line if you're
not so good at visualizing what you do
is is what you first rotate this thing
through 90 degrees and then flop the
thing over and I've taken the liberty of
doing that over here see I take my curve
and again this would be very effective
if I had overlays and wanted to slide
these for you I think it's something
that you can see on your own so all I'm
doing is what I rotate this thing
through 90 degrees and then flop over
the result and now this curve will be
the graph y equals inverse sine of X
provided you could have an inverse you
see
in the old math this was fine because
multivalued functions didn't bother us
at all however what is clear is notice
that in this particular sense the
accented curve from before becomes this
little region here and notice that the
function that I defined to be s Sub Zero
does have an inverse in other words in
terms of my new coordinate system I can
define what the curve y equals the
inverse of s Sub Zero see the idea being
what did I cannot talk about the inverse
sine now the reason I bring this up is
you'll notice that in this text in most
every text people do use this notation
and they get around it in a rather cute
way as you read the text you'll notice
the phrase called
principle values let me show you what I
mean by that what happens in the typical
texts is they'll say look at by y equals
inverse sine X we mean that X equal sine
Y but that Y is restricted to be between
the range of minus PI over 2 and PI over
2 this is called the range of principal
values now you see this sometimes causes
people to be a little bit upset because
why do you have to make this restriction
since nothing here seems to indicate
that all I hope that you can see from my
discussion and this will also be written
up in our supplementary notes so if you
need some reinforcement from what I'm
doing and the not from what I'm doing in
the lecture but in addition to what I'm
doing in the lecture you can get this
from the notes too but what I want you
to see is that what the average book
defines to be y equals inverse sine X
and then puts in the so-called principal
values simply turns out to be what I'm
calling S sub 0 inverse see after all
what was y equals S sub inverse 0
inverse X that would be rewritten how
that's equivalent to saying x equals S
sub 0 of Y but S sub 0 of Y was defined
to be what sine Y provided that Y was in
the range from minus PI over 2
two plus PI over two all right so far so
good at least that's one man's opinion
what I'd like to show you now is again
the beauty of what inverse functions
means that from this point on I can now
for example in terms of calculus get
every single calculus result I need
about derivatives of the inverse
trigonometric functions just by
restating them in terms of the ordinary
trigonometric functions for example
suppose somebody will say to me find the
derivative of inverse sine of X with
respect to X see again keeping in mind
now what this means otherwise I don't
have a function see I have to have this
thing single value this thing does it
for me look at do I know how to find the
derivative of the sine function the
answer is yes I do we've already done
that that was the last assignment in
fact in other words from X equal sine Y
from X equal sine Y can I find DX dy
certainly DX dy is cosine Y now look we
didn't want the X dy we wanted
dy DX but since we're on a one-to-one
strip here where the inverse function
does exist
notice that the relationship between DX
D Y and dy DX is that they are
reciprocals of one another that was
exactly one of the nice properties of
this notation that we've talked about on
several occasions before in other words
dy/dx is 1 over cosine Y by the way I
like this better than saying things like
the reciprocal of cosine is secant I
think when you print a book people like
to use secant instead of 1 over the
cosine simply because you can get
everything on one line and don't have to
write fractions this way but that is not
a major concern here what I do want you
to see is given that y equals inverse
sine of X can I find dy/dx the answer is
yes and by the way notice that this is
perfectly well-defined namely for a
given value of
why cosine Y you see a single value for
a given number it has only one cosine
you see I don't need single value penis
to get this result the place I have to
be careful about inverse functions
existing is that since there are many
different X values that correspond to
the same y value if I don't specify you
see if I have a multivalued function if
I don't specify what branch I'm on the
trouble will not come in when I'm
looking for dy/dx at a given value of y
it's at 99 times out of a hundred when
you're looking for dy/dx Y is given as a
function of X in other words you want to
be able to convert this in an
unambiguous way into a function of X C
that's the question that comes up there
is nothing wrong with this answer in
other words I can write down that dy DX
is 1 over cosine Y but somebody can say
to me I'd like the answer in terms of X
by the way how can I get this answer in
terms of X that's an interesting
question sometimes you see recall that y
equals inverse sine of X says the same
as what x equals sine Y now what
identity do I know I know that sine
squared plus cosine squared is 1 see x
squared is sine squared Y okay now what
do I know I know that cosine squared Y
is 1 minus sine squared Y so cosine Y is
plus or minus the square root of 1 minus
sine squared Y that's plus or minus the
square root of 1 minus x squared notice
by the way in this notation that Y
wasn't any old number Y had to be in
what range Y had to be between minus PI
over 2 and PI over 2 and as long as
that's the case notice that in that
range the cosine is positive that makes
the neck
of sign redundant see and by the way
that negative sign would not be
redundant if we hadn't restricted our
range to making the curve single valued
and one-to-one you see it's the
restriction that y has to be between
minus PI over 2 and PI over 2 that makes
this the positive square root in other
words then what we see is what that
therefore dy DX dy DX is equal to 1 over
cosine Y that's 1 over the square root
of 1 minus x squared and that's a rather
interesting result it's a rather
straightforward result I would like to
make a few comments about this thing and
one of them is where I want to summarize
with lay the tool
suppose you were given a problem of
saying I would like to trace a curve of
plot a curve and all I know about that
curve is that it's derivative at any
point is 1 over the square root of 1
minus the square of its x-coordinate do
you have to know any trigonometry do you
have to know any trigonometry to
understand that problem in other words
notice that this expression in no way
utilizes trigonometry yet to solve this
problem it appears from what we've shown
is that what that given that the slope
is this the curve itself turns out to be
y equals sine inverse X and that is an
inverse trigonometric function and so
here's a very important reason as to why
the trigonometric functions are that
important the inverse trigonometric
functions namely inverse trigonometric
functions can wind up as being what the
inverse derivative of a function which
is non trigonometric and that's reason
enough to study these things again as I
told you in my last lecture I was sadly
mistaken when I thought that
trigonometry belongs solely to the
surveyor I mean look at all the
different places that this material
comes up in and if you don't like
practical applications at least observe
that all we're really doing
here is discussing inverse functions in
terms of function itself in other words
the result that we've shown now is that
the integral of 1 over the square root
of 1 minus x squared is inverse sine X
plus a constant by the way since there
is such a connection between the inverse
trig functions and the regular trig
functions and since the trig functions
lend themselves to geometry rather
nicely I thought I would like to show
you here a rather nice device that
allows you say to solve problems like
this if you weren't given the answer in
advance in other words you see you'll
notice that in our problem by sort of
working backwards we found that the
answer to this problem was inverse sine
X plus C and the question is what if we
hadn't been given this is there a way
that we could have utilized the
knowledge of trigonometry classical
trigonometry to get a hint as to how to
do this and not only is there such a way
of doing this but the method turns out
to be so important that later in our
course in the section called techniques
of integration this comes up under the
very special name of trigonometric
substitution it works something like
this whenever you see the sum or the
difference of two squares think of a
right triangle for example in this case
if I call the hypotenuse 1 and one of
the sides X and call this angle theta
say the third side of the triangle is
the square root of 1 minus x squared and
now if I think of this this way see what
is the easiest relationship that allows
me to express fada as a trigonometric
function involving X see there are many
trigonometric functions like
relationships I can reach from this
diagram but it appears that the easiest
one is the one that says sine theta
equals x over 1 in other words sine
theta equals x and now you see from this
using differential notation and the like
and again the technique will be drilled
into you and you'll get plenty
opportunity for using this in the
exercises in the text but for now I just
want you to get to see an idea of how
the trigonometry does come back into
this you see notice that from this
diagram I get this relation now taking
the differential of both sides and
notice that I'm working with the
ordinary trig functions here which I
allegedly know at this stage I also know
from this triangle that the square root
of 1 minus x squared is cosine theta
therefore if I make these substitutions
in the integral DX over the square root
of 1 minus x squared using the
differential notation DX becomes
replaced by cosine theta D theta the
square root of 1 minus x squared becomes
replaced by cosine theta
these cancel the integral then turns out
to be what C the integral of D theta is
theta plus a constant but what was data
theta was what sine theta was X so theta
is the number whose sine is X and you
see notice how the trigonometry comes in
and helps us to solve a particular
problem to see a particular problem that
might not have seemed that obvious if we
hadn't have used the trigonometry and
again let me point out where we've used
the fact that we're using 1/2 oneness
you see when we drew this particular
triangle we assumed that theta was in
the first quadrant I mean the angle
could have been any place that for
thinking of as an angle and knowing the
sine only determines the cosine up to a
plus or minus in other words technically
speaking this should have been plus on
Lynas over here but the fact that for
principal values theta must be between
minus PI over 2 and PI over 2 and since
the cosine is positive in that range
that was why we were able to get rid of
the negative sign so again all I want
you to see from this is the fact and
this is very important
aside from the inverse trigonometric
functions being rather important we can
study them completely by giving a short
lecture because everything that we have
to know primarily came from previous
lectures the hotpot as is often the case
with inverse function notation is that
you may not be familiar with the
language that rapidly you know I
remember I sometimes when I was first
learning had to think twice about
notation like this let me start it it's
not something new here I start at the
bottom and work up when people wrote
down identities like this I found it
very difficult to think in terms of
those C I would see what does this say
it says that the inverse cosine of X is
PI over 2 minus the inverse sine of X
and I couldn't remember why that would
be true yet the funny part is if I let
say let's go back to the top now and
start if I let y equal inverse cosine X
and try to draw what that really says C
again I have to be careful about 1 to
oneness and what-have-you but if I just
mechanically translated this this would
say what x equals cosine Y cosine Y is X
that's X over 1 I've written it that way
well you know look at if this angle is y
it's kind of clear that this angle is PI
over 2 minus y now in this familiar
environment how difficult is it for me
to see that the sum of these two angles
is PI over 2 you see in that familiar
environment Minh Saul most so obvious I
wonder why anybody would want to point
it out to me yet notice that from here
how do I read this see what's another
name for Y in the angular system here Y
is that angle whose cosine is X see it's
inverse cosine X what's pi over 2 minus
y pi over 2 minus y is that angle whose
sine is X see notice that the side
that's adjacent to Y is opposite PI over
2 minus y in any at any rate PI over 2
minus y can be named inverse sine X and
so from this simple thing simple because
the language is familiar to me I get
down to the result that inverse cosine
that
plus inverse sine X is PI over two from
which of course this step here is a
triviality see again when we often deal
with inverses one of the fringe benefits
that we have is that when we get stuck
we can always reduce the given result
reverse the terminology so to speak and
return from the inverse language to the
original language see now again let me
point out that once you have a result
like this all the results of calculus
work the same way as before for example
suppose somebody says to me gee I wonder
what the derivative of inverse cosine X
s with respect to X to be sure I could
go all through this again and mimic the
results of getting the derivative for
the inverse sine but notice now by this
result this is just the derivative with
respect to X of PI over 2 minus inverse
sine of X ok but this is the derivative
of a difference
and a derivative of a difference is the
difference of the derivatives and PI
over 2 is a constant so the derivative
of PI over 2 is 0 I already know how to
differentiate inverse sine of X I've
done that before
so I want what - that derivative see I
want minus DDX inverse sine of X and
that in turn is just what well I'll
write it over here it's just minus 1
over the square root of 1 minus x
squared again another result another
result but obtained with a minimum of
new knowledge now I could go on but I
think that from here on in it's much
easier for you to dig out what you want
on your own see
I had some other material that I thought
I would give you but I think that this
was just turned out to be a little bit
on the boring side now not boring but in
the sense that either you see what I'm
driving at or you don't and what I'd
like you to do now is simply to go and
see how much of this material on inverse
trigonometric functions is yours now
free of charge if I have to pick one
thing I want to caution you about don't
be upset by the language called
principal values and what have you
everything comes out in the wash if you
recognize that we legally cannot define
an inverse function unless we have a
one-to-one function to begin with so we
must take the multi-value trigonometric
function and view it as a union of
one-to-one curves and then you see if
you want to pick a different principal
value I think if you understand what's
happening basically you'll be able to do
this thing on your own in any event
though I think this is enough on what we
call the inverse circular functions so
until next time goodbye funding for the
publication of this video was provided
by the Gabriella and Paul Rosenbaum
foundation
help ocw continue to provide free and
open access to MIT courses by making a
donation at ocw.mit.edu/donate